um okay and uh raj above three minutes  on the clock facing some serious  pressure along the g line i think it's  over it is over  she can just pick up the bishop and any  end game is completely winning for him  he'll be what two three pawns up with  the better pieces yeah  totally  once again given given a tactical chance  he doesn't miss those no knight takes  it  e5  a good game by rochelle just here  lost the threat here with bishop to d7  and  there was no coming back no  absolutely not and  i like your suggestion just uh banking  it as we say  queen takes bishop  and that's it  he's won  oh  what a game  what a what a real tactical shot by the  indian legend